we're at PI data Austin it's Saturday
sorry this is objectionable content
we're at PI data Austin it's Saturday
December 7th 2019 this is a talk about
the Python object model my name is James
Powell if you like this talk you can
follow me on Twitter I don't use this
code in fact you might want to open that
up right now because the screen may not
be large enough for you to see in the
audience so I've put up teammate link on
my Twitter feed so that you can follow
along on your computer and watch
everything I'm doing on my screen
without having to squint at the poor
resolution in front of you here so
before I get started with this tutorial
rather I want to just briefly touch upon
why this is a topic that anybody at a PI
data conference should ever care about
what we're going to talk about here is
almost entirely going to be about how
Python works how the object model in
python works how design of systems with
the Python object model works and we're
going to touch upon almost no scientific
computing and almost no absolutely no
machine learning and probably very
little data science or anything similar
to data science as an anecdote I was
very recently working with a company
that silicon photonics and the work that
they do is very deeply scientific and
very deeply mathematical however that
work is situated within a production
context they're not doing research for
silicon photonics they're actually going
and producing physical pieces of
hardware and so while as part of that
work they may employ machine learning in
order to figure out yield predictions or
in order to look at images of the chips
and try and figure out if those chips
are going to fail or not in production
fundamentally they have some kind of
production process whereby their design
needs to incorporate into some system
which can go and produce these chips
there's a lot of production level
programming beyond just the analytical
side and as part of my work with them
trying to train some of their scientists
to be able to use Python more
effectively we looked at a couple of
sample problems that were relevant to
them it turns out and was quite
surprising to me that there's very
little work in layout and placement for
silicon photonics and well that's not
the exactly the example that we use here
we'll use a much simplified example that
might touch or be within spitting
distance of that fundamentally in order
to do a layout system you're gonna have
to figure out how to write a business
rule system in order write a business
rule system you're gonna
to figure out how to use Python more
effectively than just writing functions
and so for many of you in your use of
Python as a data scientist or as a
machine learning expert you may have
really only gone so far as to write
maybe a couple of functions you might
play around with keyword arguments in
Python you might have written a couple
of classes but you've never had to write
large system design and what I try and
convey to you in this talk is that that
kind of large system design is necessary
the moment your analytical work gets
situated in some kind of business
context and somebody needs to do
something real with it for example to
drive some automated testing process or
in order to drive some yield
optimization process your code your
analytical code can't stand alone and so
you have to branch away from just using
your numpy NDA directly or your pandas
data frames directly to do some analysis
you have to start building systems and
mechanisms around that now I have a very
brief agenda for you
we've got about 90 minutes for this
tutorial and I'm not sure how the timing
will work out but I'll spend as much
time as I can showing you a couple of
things that you may or may not know this
is a pretty novice level tutorial so
there may be some content at the
beginning that you're already very
familiar with and then once I show you
some things we'll try some things we'll
work on an example perhaps together in
order to that way make use of what we
see about the Python object model in
order to actually design some kind of
system now I suspect that we won't have
enough time in the example portion to
complete this example the example that
I'll show you in a moment is about
modeling simple linear planar circuits
and automatically computing what the
current and voltage at different points
are there's a little bit of mathematical
work in there and we may not get as far
as that but hopefully we'll get just far
enough to think about how we would
design a tool that could do that using
what we see in this first portion okay
and so let's get started
so this is me on Twitter you can see
that teammate link there if you click on
it you'll see something that looks like
this this is the session that I'm gonna
be working out of and so if you go to my
Twitter feed at don't use this code and
you click on that link you won't have to
squint at the screen up here and also
all the people at home who follow me on
Twitter will get to see this talk for
free but they won't get the audio so
I'll have to figure out what we're doing
now let's get started
so let's talk about Python objects in
the Python data model and we'll start
very simply I mean a lot of your data
scientists and really when we talk about
Python objects the most you may have
ever touched upon is maybe a panda's
data frame or numpy ndra
and some dotted methods on it instead of
saying you know sort of from numpy
import some you did you know numpy ndra
dot some and you know that there's
methods and there's attributes on these
objects we haven't gotten that much
further and a lot of your code you may
just work pretty much almost entirely
with the built-in types and so it may be
the case that if we had a simple program
that was trying to model like a simple
circuit we might start by modeling each
of the components of that circle it's
just a tuple and when we can see if we
do that you know we get a simple tuple
type and it has some fields associated
with it and there's nothing too complex
about that now we actually try to
interact with that we have to access the
fields of this tuple and we'll see that
that's going to be a little bit
unpleasant we have to use direct field
accessing and it's kind of ugly it's not
clear to us what component 0 1 2 or 3
might be if this block of code that's
accessing the fields is very far away
from this block of code but you know it
kind of works and we might at some
points do you know make use of tuple D
structuring in order to give names to
these fields so it might be structure
this into four different variables and
then access those variables directly and
that's kind of nice but we still have
this fundamental problem that the tuple
when you D structure it you need to know
the order of the fields themselves and
if this code here is very far away from
this code here it may be very difficult
to keep these two and sick what we might
then try is we might try something a
little bit fancier it might say you know
what I want to be able to access the
fields of this object directly I want to
have some self documenting behavior here
so instead I'll use a dictionary and the
keys the dictionary will be the field
and the values the dictionary will be
the actual value on that field and so
that that kind of works there's nothing
too fancy there when I go about
accessing the fields it's not altogether
that difficult I just use my square
bracket indexing for the dictionary and
it's a little bit ugly a little bit
clumsy I have to add square brackets I
have to have these single quotes or
double quotes but it's a little bit
nicer than the tuple in that if I were
to add fields later I don't have to go
and change all the code that I've
already written and visually it's a
little bit closer to being self
documenting now I might then try
something very simple maybe for example
I'm a job
script programmer and I really like how
JavaScript the objects and Java scripts
can be accessed using the square bracket
syntax or the dotted syntax so I create
something like an adder dict and I just
override the get adder set adder and
Dell adder for a Python object so it
just calls the Dixon get item set item
and del item and so here I have
effectively the same code as before
except now I can access the fields by
name using this dotted syntax just like
I can in JavaScript now this is kind of
silly and please don't ever do this this
is a really bad idea it's doesn't gain
you a whole lot and I don't know why
people just really seem to hate typing
those extra square brackets and the
double quotes but if you really think
about it you really dive a little bit
deeper and you think is it that silly
it's not really that silly because if we
were to write this as a normal Python
object you know I just a regular class
with an init method I'm going to look at
that class we'll see that inside that
class there's a attribute called dict
with two underscores before and after
and it's pretty much the same dictionary
as a dictionary above and that dict
object is where it's storing all the
instance state so we might say you know
what this adder dict structure despite
being a very bad idea and by the way if
you try and look up how to write that
there's two formulations that you'll see
people talk about online and one of them
is a terrible terrible formulation where
you set the dict of the instance to
itself and you end up with potential
memory pressure because it has a
circular reference and so when the
garbage collector tries to collect this
there's some delay in its collection and
so don't do it at all but if you're
gonna do it use a formulation I showed
you above however what argument you
might make is that it's not altogether
that different than how Python
dictionaries are actually implemented
under the covers now if we try that one
of the things that we might have run
across if we've ever done some object
modeling of Python is we have some
system and we have lots of these kind of
resistor objects because we're modeling
humongous circuits and we're seeing
that's using a lot of memory and it
turns out that this formulation of the
Python object that has this dict objects
inside of it representing all of the
instance date does use a lot of memory
and so we can look at this object and we
can ask the system the system on Jul
what's the size of this thing and this
this module will tell us how it's 48
bytes in size and so it's pretty big for
one individual piece of data that really
doesn't store a whole lot of them for
just some part number some manufacturer
and just a resistance presumably in base
units and ohms of this component now if
we were to really get a bug about us to
try and do some kind of management or
some sort of analysis of the memory use
of our program we could go pretty far
there's quite a few tools in Python
especially in Python 3 for doing memory
management there's a trace malloc module
and the trace malloc module you can take
snapshots and when you take snapshots
you can see what got allocated in
between those two snapshots and so for a
very simple example like this we could
see is this thing really as large as I
thought it was and if you actually run
this you can see on average this line 11
which is the creation of this one object
indicated had 48 bytes of additional
memory allocated so it probably takes
about 48 bytes to store this structure
which is still very large but at least
we have some fixed bound on how big it
is and we can play around with trying to
make it smaller now bear in mind another
thing I would never advise you to do is
the moment anybody gives you a project
that's our applications using too much
memory can you figure out how to reduce
that amount of memory and by the way
it's written in Python just find a new
job because it's those projects are
always giant dead ends because even
though this analysis kind of looks like
it works it only works like this because
we're dealing with very simple
heap-allocated Python objects the moment
you start to do memory analysis on large
Python programs you'll see that there
are structures within a Python
interpreter like free lists in your
attribute lookup mechanism that never
get D allocated so an actual Python
program may not necessarily deallocate
memory that it no longer uses it'll just
hit a high-water mark and stay at that
watermark so all of these exercises
where somebody says oh our app is using
a gigabyte of memory and how do you
improve the memory usage and then you go
and you try and change a bunch of things
you won't be able to get the effects
that you think you might be able to get
and fundamentally unless you really
understand what memory means on all the
platforms or application runs like on
your Windows platform you understand
what that VSS and an RSS and all that
means or when you do free at your Linux
terminal you understand what all those
numbers mean it's a dead end
and so we won't go any deeper into this
example because this is pretty much a
dead end career wise if you ever get a
project like that and also analytically
because the typical the typical answer
to this in Python is to use a MEK
provided by the Python object model
called slots which no longer or in which
a Python object no longer has an
instance dictionary so you save all that
memory from that extra dictionary and
instead you have explicit locations for
where the instance date of that type is
stored and so here this particular
object cannot store additional
information outside of the number
manufacturer resistance if I try to
amend this to add another field at
runtime it'll fail you can see it'll
fail it doesn't have that attribute and
so it loses that dynamic behavior in
exchange for presumably being a little
bit smaller in fact but in fact in this
case it's not smaller it's actually
bigger and so you can see just don't
don't bother with memory analysis in
Python it's not worth your time now what
you should do instead and the guidance
that I should give you it's a very
important very high-level piece of
guidance for whenever you're writing a
program or even working on the example
that we're going to look at you know
after we go through some of these topics
is to think about Python as an
orchestration language Python was
originally called back in the day when
we were trying to popularize Python
though the ultimate glue language the
ultimate orchestration language a
language which takes components that are
written in other languages like C or C++
and orchestrates they're mechanisms
inside those components which might be
some kind of analytical code that
somebody wrote ten years ago that nobody
wants to rewrite but we don't want to
today be designing experiments or
setting up models and still using malloc
infer you I have a nicer interface for
that well then we reserved the
manipulation of the problem the
manipulation of the business entities or
the manipulation of the experiment to
the Python level and the actual core
computational use to this library and C
or C++ or Fortran or whatever it might
be and so those entities turn into what
I like to call restricted computation
domains a very common one that you're
almost certainly familiar with is the
numpy ND array if you think about it a
Python object is always boxed there's no
distinction in Python between boxed and
unboxed objects like there is in Java
and Python everything is boxed and so
everything is an object that you can
call methods on that also is
heap-allocated and takes or with the
exception of certain things that might
be interned or other optimizations but
for the most part our heap-allocated
and take a large amount of space
whereas with the numpy NDA the content
of the umpire in the array are
contiguous machine types so they're
unboxed well what happens in Python is
you often design your system so that you
have business entities that are unboxed
entities then you put them into a
computation domain like a numpy and D
array or a panda's data frame inside
that computation domain they get unboxed
so that the computation domain which
restricts your access to those entities
can then perform certain specializations
and optimizations for example putting
these in some kind of cache contiguous
structure so that you can do fast sums
or taking Python integers and turning
them into Machine integers with specific
bit widths so then you can use processor
level instructions in order to compute
operations on them and you can see more
or less that pattern occurs in any code
example uses pandas or numpy or network
X or any of these other tools and so in
the case of numpad you might see some
code that looks like this you have three
unboxed Python integers you put them
into a numpy ndra you perform some
computation inside that array once it's
inside that ndra
because it is a restricted computation
to me because numpy says these are
machine types there they are
fixed bit with integers so they are in
64's there is no inter dependencies
between these items it can then choose
to perform this element-wise
multiplication in whatever fashion it
finds is most efficient so it can auto
paralyze it or I could use machine level
instructions or it could use some kind
of more sophisticated processor level
instructions to auto vector to vectorize
this multiplication and then you pull
them back out and so you can see there's
almost always this case of you have the
unboxed the boxed object you put into
the computation in main which draws a
box around everything the objects
themselves become unboxed and then you
pull them back out as boxed objects and
so this is tends to be the pattern for
where large object systems work and so
as we go through the example one of the
things you should think about is anytime
you're working on some production system
in Python and you're modeling in terms
of Python objects one of the limitations
that you have is it's just gonna be slow
it's gonna be slow and it's gonna use a
lot of memory and it's gonna be slow and
use a lot of memory because python
objects are heap allocated they're not
contiguous and so even if you have
computations that should be local in
some fashion you won't get that locality
in terms of where the
objects are in the heap and also they're
just huge right I mean in the previous
example we needed 48 bytes to store what
two strings and an int that's a lot of
space to store not a lot of data and the
reason is there's a lot of overhead for
a Python object you need to manage what
the type is you need to manage its
reference count and so forth and so on
and so what you should think is whenever
you're designing a system like that
it'll inevitably turn into a situation
where you draw some box around the
business entity some manager box and
inside of that you create a computation
domain and then you restrict access to
it and that's how you get your
performance back and so one of the
things when I talk about this people
sometimes bring up is they like to say
well is a restricted computation domain
a monad and it's not really a monad you
think about monads you often think about
putting a box around items and
interacting with them only through some
specific API in relation to that box but
what makes a monad interesting I think
is the bind operation and there's really
no notion of a bind operation here and
also the ability to then provide
Combinator's on top of them we don't
have that this is a lot simpler than a
monad it's just some computation domain
that gives you the ability to specify
how the underlying data is stored and
how you process underlying data so what
happens when you do these things in
Python is you end up having some kind of
manager class and you end up writing
code that looks like it has some manager
class that manages everything and so for
our resistor network let's say we had
some product that had some resistors on
it we ought to provide some computation
on that maybe that computation would be
that we wanted to sum or find the mean
resistance of all these resistors and so
we might have some individual Python
object that represents this boxed
individual business entity that stores
information that's not computational
nature like the manufacturer and the
part number are not computational denchu
they're not used in any computations but
they're used for your production
management of that system for example
you ingest a bill of materials and that
bill of materials needs to know what's
the part number and what's the
manufacturer and what's the resistance
you then perform some computation
validate this product or this piece of
hardware and then you say ok I valuated
it now who do I go and send shipping
orders to and so you need that business
information but it's not actually used
as part of the core computation then you
might have some computational entity and
that this product here represents this
computational entity it takes the
components that you give it in this case
just a bunch of resistors and it
extracts the information for them and
puts them into a
it's data frame now if you remember how
pin is not a frame works internally it
has this block manager in the case of
the pan has data frame here it'll
probably be a numpy and D right
so effectively my manager class then has
none PI India race which are now
contiguous machine types structures
where these computations become very
efficiently and when I add a get item to
pull items out of this computation
domain I can then restore the boxed
Python structure by just reconstructing
the resistor object on the way out and
so what you can see here in this example
is you know we start with a product and
we give it a couple of Python objects it
deconstruct those Python objects to pull
the information out stores in an
efficient format and that pan is not a
frame I can then perform operations on
it like I can do a dot mean operation
that will then be performed in a very
efficient fashion and then I can ask it
to give me the object back out and
they'll reconstruct the object in the
way out so this is how these structures
tend to look and you wouldn't you really
wouldn't do something like this in C++
and C++ you'd often just write a C++
object and you assume that the you know
zero cost abstraction H or C++ would
make this automatically efficient and
Python you have to add this additional
abstraction that it's just a layer
because the pure Python objects are very
good for orchestrating the operation
you're trying to perform but they're not
very good at performing or representing
the data in a fashion that is optimal
for computation so with that set aside
let's go back to our friend the tuple
and we probably don't want to really use
a tuple to represent any sort of data in
our program even if we're doing you know
simple data analysis and all the only
sophisticated type we deal with is maybe
our input data and then we stick it into
an umpire in the array we probably won't
don't want to really use tuples passed
maybe the first prototyping stage
instead we might want to use something
like from the collections module the
named tuple which is just the mechanism
by which we can automatically generate
code that subclasses from a tuple object
and in that subclass in that automatic
generated code gives you very nice
things like a nice principal
representation if we look at this code
you can see it gives us a very nice
printable representation of the
underlying object and we have this
dotted attribute access to these fields
so we don't have this unfortunate organ
ah mcc's of the under of the tuple where
we have to access the fields by position
and then if we add extra fields and we
have to go and update our exist
code now the limitation of the name
tuple is that it's still a tuple and so
you still have that immutability which
may or may not be desirable for you but
fundamentally this is probably better
than your underlying tuple structure but
if you were to show me some code and you
said I'm modeling some system and it's
in a production system and I started by
representing all of my objects that's
just built in Python types tuples and
dates did I do the right thing or not
the real answer to learn from all of
this is that one of the design
principles of Python is spend more time
with your family in other words if
you're given a task and that task is
loosely defined as most business tasks
in a production context are and you're
told I need you to do this one specific
task well then do the bare minimum that
you can do in order to achieve that one
requirement and what you'll see as we go
through some of these examples is Python
gives you certain ways to take a very
simple representation of an object and
to increase its complexity as the
complexity of the requirements increase
and so the answer is not in Python to
take a C++ approach to designing an
object to designing your system in C++
maybe the approach that you might take
is you first think really hard about the
underlying types that you're
representing and the operations between
them and you write everything out and if
you get it right then each marginal
requirement that you get is only a very
small marginal amount of work and so you
can think there's a lot of upfront
effort then a very small marginal amount
of work as you go and Python we try to
get something a little bit more linear
in the sense that you produce a very
marginal amount of work today
wait until the requirement comes in and
then see if you can extend that without
causing changes to code that uses the
code that you've written and so things
like the elevation from bear tuple to a
named tuple in his example because if I
had started this example with just a
regular tuple other than the dotted
lookup anywhere else so this code might
be used would work and so turning this
into a named tuple only turn this into
rather turning this here into a named
tuple just means that I add some
functionality but I don't subtract an
existing footer I don't have to rewrite
any code that was already using this
structure and so this is maybe the idea
behind some of how Python is designed
really keep it as simple as possible
from day one
if you're given a requirement try and
get it done by 5:00 p.m. go home spend
time with your family and then wait
until tomorrow when you get a new
requirement to then escalate the
complexity of the code that you've
written and so as we go deeper into this
tutorial we're going to see some
examples where the complexity is indeed
very very very high and there's some
mechanisms that are very sophisticated
and maybe not mechanisms you want to use
from day one there are mechanisms that
you should employ when a requirement
says the only way for you to get this
done with the system that you have
written here is to use this the
sophisticated tool don't use it from day
one because you're just gonna be sitting
writing code all night and you're your
family's gonna be at home just crying
where's I said like you said he'd be
home at 8:00 p.m. so one thing that I
want to draw your attention to and and
maybe one of the motivations for why
we're going to look into some of the
sophistication is if you look at where
we started this first section of our
tutorial with representing this resistor
object is just a tuple and you look at
where we've ended up representing is a
name tuple there's one little piece
that's missing in the tuple
representation we had one extra field
and that extra field was the type of
component that we had and the reason we
might have that extra field is we might
have some code somewhere that says look
at the type and if it's a resistor do
this particular operation and if it's a
capacitor do this other operation or if
it's a resistor then we know that we
know a certain relationship between the
current that passes through it and the
voltage or if it's a capacitor it's a
completely different relationship and
may be nonlinear for certain circuit
elements and when we turn this into a
named tuple we see that the code
slightly changes instead of directly
checking the type we use this is
instance method that's provided to imply
that in the built-ins and ultimately
these two blocks of code do the same
thing they're checking some they're
checking some object and see what its
type is and then they're dispatching on
that type to perform some operation this
isn't even type based polymorphism this
is just very simple check are you a
resistor then do this if you're a
capacitor to do that now one thing that
is very interesting and meaningful here
is notice that the code at the top and
the bottom is now moving towards using
what you might call a shared vocabulary
one of the things that we can think
about for the Python object model is
that it provides us with a shared
vocabulary that forces our code to maybe
integrate better
into the Python vernacular into Python
systems as a whole in other words if I
ask you give me an API for figuring out
if a thing is a type of a thing well one
way that you could do is you could
represent those things as tuples and you
could say well there's a field and check
to see if that field is exactly this
string another way you could do it is
you could say in Python I'm given a
built-in function and it's called is
instance and that built-in function
reads to somebody reading through that
code as asking this question of us is X
a thing of this type and how I implement
that check may be customizable and in
this particular case it is very
customizable we'll see later how to
customize that instance check but
fundamentally what you're looking to do
is you're looking to add a particular
vocabulary to employ a particular
vocabulary that is available to you and
made available to you by the built-in
functions and by the objects the the
data model in Python so that your code
reads very closely to the intention of
what you have and so when you read
through this code it reads as less
mechanical or it should read as less
mechanical it should read as asking the
exact intention of what you were trying
to ask are you an instance of this thing
whereas this code here looks a lot more
mechanical Oh is your zeroth field this
particular field and it doesn't have
that close correspondence between the
intention and the mechanism that's used
to express that intention so let's talk
about the basic object model in Python
what we know about the basic object
model in Python is that we often use it
to implement what we might call
protocols and so you can think for a
very simple Python object like this
resistor class there's some protocol
that represents initialization and
there's some syntax associated with that
and there's some close correspondence
between the syntax that that invokes a
protocol and the way that we go and we
implement that protocol so for example
the syntax here would be this type name
parenthesis syntax that is what we call
initializing and so when we look at this
line we say ok initialize a resistor
with this particular data and we need to
implement what that means for this
resistor type so we write internet
function and the net function is very
simple it just sets fields there's
nothing more complicated than that and
if we do this we can see it works and
it's ok
although the printed representation of
this thing doesn't look very nice at all
kind of ugly and so we might think ok
what's what's missing here what do we
need to implement in order to improve
the
printed representation and we may know
that in Python there's a method called
repper it's another method provided to
at the built-ins and it means give me
the human principal representation of
this object and so what we might think
is given that close correspondence
between some built-in function or some
syntax or some teepee or some other
bytecode you'll see in a moment there
should be some way to implement that
protocol and in the case of implementing
the built-in repre it means implementing
the underscore repper data model method
and so if we go ahead and implement this
data model method then we've satisfied
the ability for this object to get a
human principal representation and you
can see here when I print this out it as
a human principal a human understandable
representation it doesn't tell us just
the type of the object and the object's
ID it tells us information about that
object now if we go to the part of the
Python documentation Doc's not
python.org / 3 / I don't know just go
there and then find it from there you'll
see that actually just Google for a data
model method or for data model Python
you'll see that there are certain rules
around the implementation of all these
protocols there are certain guidelines
what you'll see often is that these
protocols are rightfully called
protocols because usually what you're
doing is you're taking some fixed
mechanism by which you answer a question
or perform some operation you're hooking
into it to add some small amendment or
some small addendum or some small
modification and then you're dispatching
back to that same protocol on either
constituent object or on base class and
so one example of that is if you go to
that data model page and you look at the
rules around repper one of the rules
that people generally try to abide by
when they're writing the wrapper is that
the thing that this prints out to be
able to cut and paste and your Python
terminal and when you cut and paste it
you should be able to create an
equivalent object of the same term that
doesn't work because you can see this is
a numeric expression not a string and
this is a variable name not a string so
there's something missing here I need to
put extra quotes around that it may seem
like a very minor thing
oh I'm just missing some quotes I should
just add some extra quotes here and if I
add these extra quotes here and here
then what I get is a repper that
conforms to the standard practice where
if I cut and paste this line right here
and I paste it on my terminal
I'll get another resistor object that
should be equivalent to the first one
but what you might think is well this
case it may not make sense or maybe it
might make sense what if this field here
has double quotes in it maybe that field
has single quotes in it and then I have
to figure out how to do that quoting I
have to come up with some complex some
complex code to figure out how to quote
that thing or to escape quotes and that
thing and instead what I'm missing is
that final piece which is these
protocols almost always dispatch back to
the same protocol and either constituent
object or on a base class and so the
answer here should be something like
this the only real change that I've made
is I put us a bang R at the end of this
I put this field formatting specifier in
this F string and what that means is
this is the equivalent to just calling
repper inside my repper
these are equivalent and so the guidance
here is that whenever you're
implementing with these protocols almost
always you're gonna call the protocol
from within the protocol and so all
you're really doing in that
implementation of that protocol is just
adding your slight modification and then
dispatching back to the protocol to do
the work as expected and when I finally
make this work and I add an EQ here so
that I can actually see they're equal
and I add in I cut and paste that result
then I'll be printed on this line over
here we'll see everything works as
expected and so I get the resistor
printed out nicely if I cut and paste it
at my terminal its back equal to the
original object and so that's the
general guidance that I have for repper
this is why you might this may answer
why for example if you ever opened a
file in Python say the file that we'll
look at in a moment network dot JSON as
F and you tried to print out the wrapper
for that thing and you looked at it you
saw it had angle brackets before and
after and some objects you might see in
Python have there's angle brackets
before and after you might wonder why
that's in the wrapper
well this is not violet Python syntax
and so in some cases impossible for that
human principal representation to give
you something that you could cut and
paste and get an equivalent version of
the same of the original object in the
case of a file it's because there's
going to be a lot of hidden information
here like the file pointer at the
burning system-level or certain buffers
that may not be recreated Belen any
fashion or there could be write buffers
that may not be you may not be able to
recreate in any fashion to reconstitute
this and so they explicitly put these
ankle brackets before and after the
repper to indicate that what I'm showing
you is a human printable representation
that could not ever be reconstituted
into the original object because there's
some hidden state that is impossible for
us to capture it's no longer some kind
of immutable or stateless object like a
resistor type was or some object with
some controllable invisible and
manageable state now it turns out that
this stuff can kind of be a little
tricky to get right because let's say I
start with my resistor and I add in like
a variable resistor like a potentiometer
into this problem and my potentiometer
just subclasses from my resistive
nothing too fancy and I create a
potentiometer here and maybe I should
call it p4 potentiometer and then I just
try and print it out nothing fancy at
all what you'll see is that the
represent right tells me it's a resistor
but it's not it's a potentiometer and
it's just simply wrong and the reason
for that is you know when I wrote this
rep really I hard-coded the name of the
type and so maybe I need to do something
fancier I need to dynamically present
the name of the type as part of the
repper by actually looking up the type
at runtime and printing that out now is
this an actual improvement well in this
particular case you can see it prints
this out correctly but this isn't quite
an improvement because it turns out that
this idea of dispatching back to the
underlying protocol doesn't always work
for every protocol in a very nice
fashion it's often the case that you do
have to just go and write the
boilerplate to re-implement something
and repairs are very clean a very clear
example of that because if in my
potentiometer class I then add in maybe
the max and the the min and the max if
you remember a potentiometer has kind of
a slider on it and kind of slide it
there and it goes between two levels of
resistance and then wherever the slider
is that's the current resistance so
maybe I add in a minute of Max resistant
field but then the rest of the fields
are the same as the underlying resistor
so it really is just extending this
underlying resistor class you know I got
to write a new repper because I have
these extra fields I need to print out
and how does this represent it might be
able to dynamically figure out what the
type of the class is like we saw in the
previous example
but I'll never be able to figure out to
print out those extra fields as well and
so I'll have to rewrite this and
actually I missed one field here so
we'll add in that extra field so I
should do it like yes so there you go
now you might then look at this and say
tell me doesn't sit right with me
because every time I implement these
protocols like I implement Len or get
adder or get or get item or call I'm you
almost always invariably reeling that
protocol and here I'm not really doing
that
there's just seems to be a lot of
boilerplate with this repper and
unfortunately it's unavoidable because
the only other way you can avoid this is
if you go ahead and try and create your
own protocols or your own object system
and so here's an example of something
that you might try to do you might try
to tell the resistor type here you know
what these are the fields that you have
these are the fields that you have and
along the way we'll also make those
slots because for some reason people
seem to really love talking about slots
even though I think they're just
absolutely boring this can be and so
because I can identify what the fields
are then when I write the wrapper for my
resistor down here I can just have it
dynamically pick out what those fields
are gonna be and print that out and then
that means that any subclass of this
just needs to say oh I'm a potentiometer
I'm just all the resistor fields plus
these two extra fields and I get that
repper for free and what you can think
that you're doing here is you're kind of
creating your own universe your own set
of protocols your own object model
you're creating a set of guidance or set
of rules that every type in this
hierarchy needs to abide by in order to
be consistent because it could be the
case that for example you subclass
something from this a different type of
resistor and you know this is some some
other type of resistor and you forget to
fill in the fields and if you forget to
fill in the fields and the repertory
thing fails and so you might
additionally need to add in some
guarantee mechanisms or some mechanism
by which you can enforce from the base
class down to the derived class that you
fill out this object model but
fundamentally what you're what you're
seeing is you're beginning to diverge
from what a normal Python object with
the rules of a normal Python object
dictate by adding your own rules if you
create your own subclass here you also
have to fill out these extra field this
extra
field structure otherwise you start to
potentially lead to inconsistencies in
the way this operates but for the most
part this works now is this worthwhile
is all of this additional mechanism
worthwhile in this particular case no
all you save yourself is a little bit of
boilerplate then you would have written
just just written once that would have
just been a cut and paste job it's
almost certainly not worthwhile to start
adding these complex object systems on
top of the Python based objects just to
save yourself a job they just give to
the intern right and so there are
definitely cases where you want to build
up these object systems for example if
you're designing a library like an ORM
of course you need to have some kind of
object system you need to have a tight
set of rules for how people subclass
from your base ORM object but that's
something as simple as this no it's
really not worth it and so I think one
of the other guidance is for how to make
best use of the Python object model
let's really don't overthink it
sometimes there is just cut and paste
sometimes there's boilerplate whenever
you're writing your knits there's some
on some necessary amount of boilerplate
there and just live with it just learn
to live with it because trying to get
around it starts getting you into this
deeper and deeper and deeper hole
because for example this object system
has other duplication right these fields
here are repeated here so am I gonna
automatically generate the units as well
and what if the anit needs to take some
modality that's not part of the field
and then how do I build into that
abstraction the ability to have these
these additional modalities and this is
gonna become more and more and more
complex as it starts to interact with
the real world whereas the cut and paste
approach would give you that infinite
flexibility where oh this particular
subclass needs to have an extra flag and
that flag is not a field it's just some
modality flag for guiding the rest like
the units in which the resistance are in
and then you can see that just
everything will fall apart and so it
really it really you really have to be
judicious about using that now if you
really wanted to be clever
you could try you could really try very
hard to use some of pythons
introspective nature in order to get
around not building your own object
system but fundamentally you're
basically doing the same thing and so in
this example here instead of identifying
what the fields are I use the inspect
module signature to look at the
signature of the init to figure out from
the signature
of the anit what the fields would be and
then to automatically generate the
rapper from that and so the magic line
here is just this line here which figure
out what figures out what the fields are
and then automatically Princeton so you
see both of these representation where
if there were some modality here this
modality would be interpreted as a field
not a mode and I'd have to figure I'd
have to say here oh look at all the look
at all of the parameters to this init
function that happened to not be keyword
our only arguments or whatnot or you'd
have to get people to say you know this
is a read-only field and have to use
annotations or some nonsense like that
and it's you're just you're just adding
a lot of complexity for what is really
just a little bit of boilerplate that
you just have to suck up the right now
all of this kind of discussion of an
object system or creating an auto system
should remind you of something else that
you've seen in the Python standard
library Python 3.7 and we got the
ability to or we got in the standard
library our own version of tools that
have existed outside the standard
library for some time which is automatic
generation of the boilerplate for a
class and the standard libraries they're
called data classes and these are
immutable types that automatically
generate a repper and in it for you
you use the variable annotations that
were added in Python 3.7 I believe in
order to specify information that's
never actually used anywhere so don't
think that this is actually checking
that these are strings in a float no it
doesn't actually do that but maybe your
maybe your type hinting tool does that I
don't know I don't use those I don't
think they're that useful either but a
lot of a lot of a lot of code for free
and so from our perspective of doing the
least amount of work in order to
implement the system I think there's
something worthwhile here and I am
personally a big fan of data class
although I would say you know it doesn't
really matter what you put there unless
you're really using the type int and
stuff although maybe if you were to
extend data classes yourself to add your
own mechanisms you might put something
here that might be more interesting like
some automatic validator or initializer
something better than the pepp 44 type
int Inc
stuff because I mean the the variable
annotation just gives you some structure
place to put some information which you
could then retrieve as part of your
object system now one of the things I
want to draw your attention to is that
as we can see and as we saw in the
previous example as we get deeper into
the Python object modeling we implement
all these underscore functions we're
effectively creating a vocabulary that
describes how our objects interact and
how we interact with those objects and
so in this case we have some network of
circuit elements and they and we can ask
that network how big are you like how
many elements that you have what would
that what would that mean how many
elements you have how many connections
you have how many nodes you have but
there's some particular meaning that you
might you might assume when somebody
asks how big is this network and the way
that you might implement that is by
using Len Len is a very natural way in
Python to express trying to figure out
how big this thing is
and then you implement it with your
underscore Len or you might need to
retrieve something from this network for
example you might need to retrieve one
of the elements by it's part number and
you can think this idea of retrieving
something corresponds in Python to the
square bracket syntax and so you to
implement get item and this would be
better than writing your own you know
get part by number of function or your
own get size function because what
you're thinking is that the thinking
behind this is by sticking close to the
vocabulary provided to you by the
built-in functions and a Python based
data model what what you're doing is
you're reusing a vocabulary that already
exists that describes the way that
Python objects that people are very
familiar with
interact you're encouraging the objects
that you create to better integrate with
the core language itself you're
encouraging the code that you write to
minimize the additional entities that
somebody needs to understand in order to
understand the code that you wrote and
so I would say that implementing Len
might be a net benefit over writing a
getsize even though you might say this
is more explicit this is something where
somebody looks a Python programmer looks
at Len on an object and they intuitively
think this is saying what's the size of
this thing and as long as this network
has one unique privilege notion of its
size in this case we're assuming that
that would be the number of elements
then this this produces code that's
fluent
integrates nicely into existing Python
code and that minimizes the amount of
additional API documentation we have to
have because you can think here if you
had a get size you'd have to write some
API documentation and I suspect that the
API documentation right for Len would be
much smaller Len would just be give the
slides of network in elements whereas
here you might need to add additional
qualifications
now unfortunately one of the downsides
is it's not always clear where this or
how this vocabulary is specified or what
the terms in this vocabulary mean unless
you've been using Python for a very long
time and there may be cases where you
look at how Python works and you might
assume that there's a vocabulary in
place when there really isn't and one
example that I ran into a very long time
ago was the hash method in Python we
know there's a built-in function called
hash in Python and if we look at that we
could say oh this gives us some unique
identifier for an object that might
represent this object in a fixed space
and a fixed integer space and so I might
then use that if I need to store my
objects in my own custom object database
or store them in some fashion that needs
to be retrieved off of disk I might say
well I need to find some way to compute
this hash you know what I'll just use
the built-in hash protocol I'll use the
built-in hash function and the
underscore hash method and that's how
I'll make it work
but unfortunately that's not what hash
means in Python hash means something
much narrower in Python it means give me
a single integer that can then be used
to compute what the array index for how
this thing will be stored in a set or a
dictionary because for example if you
have a Python object and it's hash
always returns negative one it does not
always return negative one it is
impossible in C Python for the hash of
an object to be any to be negative one
always it scores to a negative two-y
because deep in the bowels of c python
this negative one value is used as a c
value to indicate that there was an
error in the computation of the hash so
every time a hash every time in
underscore hash method returns negative
one
it gets coerced to a negative two
there's a line of code there where it
says if it's negative one return
negative two and so you can think why
does this make sense because it doesn't
happen pi pi doesn't happen in any
alternative Python at any non C Python
implementation well it's because this
protocol does not mean oh just compute a
hash they could be used in many
different places and could be used in
order to
store.this an object database is stored
on disk this means very specifically and
very narrowly compute something that
will be used by the Python interpreter
itself for the purposes of that running
instance of that Python interpreter and
no more and sometimes that small and
very subtle distinction may not be
visible when you're reading through the
documentation we're reading through
Python code for the most part these
these corner cases are fairly rare but
there are these corner cases where you
look at something you say oh this is a
nice way to express an idea using the
built in using the Python data model and
it's not because there's some nuance
there for example if you look a little
bit deeper
hache may also in some cases add some
randomization factor in order to avoid
DDoS attempts for python systems that
are built to have some kind of user
exposure and so what the actual hash
value that's produced by this method may
not always be predictable and it may
change between different invitations of
the same interpreter with the same
version of Python and the same code
based on the same machine and so it's
not something that you can reliably use
it can use to compute something and so
in this case it would actually be the
case that if you wanted to have your
objects serializable into your own
object dictionary and they need to have
some unique identifier in that sorry in
that object store then you might
actually have to write your own hash
without the underscores function and you
might have to now duplicate the entities
because this object here might then have
both a hash of something well just do it
may have both this and its own hash
method and this may seem unnecessarily
macey unnecessarily redundant but this
one is being used for internal use by
the Python interpreter in this one's
being used for some kind of external
protocol and so being able to
distinguish what these protocols are
whether they're actually for broad used
to describe the interactions in your
object or they're just used for hooking
into the Python runtime can sometimes be
a little bit tricky to see although I
can tell you that there's fairly few
circumstances where this occurs most of
the time you can reuse these protocols
to express whatever meaning you want an
example of that would be and you this
made this may make some of you think of
the path Lib module in Python and one of
the things that people like
the path Lib module is it gives you
controllable programmatic access to
paths like you can switch out suffixes
and get parent paths you can resolve
them you get relative paths and absolute
paths so trying to do string
manipulation so what you do is you put
that string into some structured you put
that string data into some structured
object that object then gives you
structured ways to manipulate it but
other people like it because you can use
the solidus you can use the slash to
mean the same thing as like you know
directory slash directory and this is
this this I think was controversial
because I think a lot of people really
objected to the use of what appears to
be a mathematical operator to just kind
of do some cute syntax and you can
really go as far as you want with this
and so here's a stupid example of using
map mole the app sign to automatically
generate emails this is absolutely
pointless this is not an arithmetic
operation all of the assumptions that
you might bring to mat Mall like for
example it performs some non
element-wise operation you know it may
not be it may not be associated or may
not be commutative those all break this
is just gimmicky syntax and some people
seem to like that I don't know I think
you can go a little bit too far so this
is an example of going way too far now
that said path Lib for step for whatever
reason people seem to like so you can't
you can't complain too much now let me
let me dive a little bit deeper into
maybe some of the motivation behind all
of this because I think that sometimes
looking at some of these mechanics might
be overwhelming and so I want to give
you a case study a real-world or
simplified example of a real-world case
study of where some of these mechanisms
are valuable and one of the one of the
thought processes you can have by for
when you might use some of the
mechanisms especially some of the more
sophisticated mechanisms we're about to
look at is to think about how use of the
Python object model not only can give
you this common vocabulary to describe
in relations between your objects but it
can also give you the ability to
rearrange the complexity of your program
to serve certain human needs so give me
an example let's say that we have a
simple report and that report has some
information before and after so we've
actually done the circuit analysis and
we figured out where the currents are
and we can see given some layout of the
circuit some dialing on that
potentiometer the
sar where they were in the before line
and then after we dial that
potentiometer differently the currents
are there and for some reason in this
particular example one of the currents
dropped out the other one dropped in so
maybe we dialed one of the
potentiometers so that it became so that
there was no longer like a span between
those two nodes and one of the things we
might want to do is me I want to
actually compare like what's the before
in the after so we might want to
generate a simple report I'm gonna
generate a simple report that looks like
this these are the four currents these
are the after currents this is the
absolute Delta and that's the percentage
Delta and it turns out that in many
fields this report was actually
something that I spent quite a bit of
time doing when I was when I was
building PNL systems for front office
trading desks because there's often the
case that what you'd have to do is you'd
have to come out with a new financial
model for a bond and you'd have to see
how that model compared against the old
model so you might price this over a set
of days and look at the differences and
one of the common things that when you
generate a report like this somebody
asks for is they want to be able to flag
things that are severely out of variance
because if you look at the differences
here you can see for current one it went
from ten I guess amps to 14 amps that's
a meaningful change current to went from
15 to 14 that could have been you know
if we were using some kind of kickoffs
Laplace you know inverse matrix
formulation this could have been some
kind of rounding error so that might not
even be worthwhile to look at and then
here you can see this current 5 went
from 1 to 50 so clearly something went
really wild with resistance on that span
because we increase the we increase the
current by you know five thousand
percent and so how might we want to look
at that well in the confines of a very
simple text report maybe we'll just add
a little star to the end of the lines
well at the end of the lines add a
little star we'll add a little flag
so we'll say you know looking at the
percent difference if it's greater than
50 percent at a star star if it's
greater than 10 percent a little star
and as simple it can be if we look at a
report now we can see we stored that and
that as being very meaningful things to
look at it's a very common thing to do
imagine if you're comparing two runs of
a model and you need to figure out where
were the meaningful changes from day 1
to day 2 or the meaningful changes
before and after we made a change now
the question is is it likely that this
functionality here when you're
constructing that flag is it likely that
might appear in different places within
your system of course
because the guidance for how generate
this flag might be something that is
necessary not only in this particular
report but in any other subsequent
report that you do maybe you have some
model and you're looking at its
performance its memory use I'm sorry or
maybe even you're looking at its
predictive capabilities and this
flagging there's percentage flag and
some of you want to use in all three
places and so instead of cutting and
pasting these five lines of code you
need to find some abstraction allows you
to reuse the same flagging mechanism
same percent flagging mechanism in three
places
now as a you know a data scientist who's
maybe mostly familiar with writing
functions or mostly comfortable writing
functions you might say this is a
perfect example of refactoring just
extract this to a function so I have a
simple function called get flag I give
it the percentage difference it looks at
the percentage difference and it gives
me that flag and I generate my report
from that and everything works as I
expected and now in the different parts
of my system where I need to use that
flag I just reuse this function this is
very basic modularity right but I want
to suggest you maybe a different
approach to take and a different
approach to take that might comport a
little bit better with what we've been
looking at so far about building this
common vocabulary but also about how we
can rearrange the complexity of a
program using this Python object system
and so as an aside I have a small
question for you we know that there
exist many protocols in Python like get
adder get item and call get I get adders
for looking up an attribute by dada Dame
syntax get item is by looking at
something with square brackets and call
is whenever you invoke something with
the parentheses after it what is the
difference between these three clearly
there's a difference between get adder
and the other two because the argument
for get adder is always a string with
maybe underscores in it but you can
never really implement get item with get
adder that's impossible
but what's enormous we can get item and
call like why does it matter if I chose
in my protocol to use square brackets
here are parentheses you might say what
it conveys to the reader of this code
may be different in this case you're
conveying look something up in this case
you're conveying compute something but
mechanically there really is no
difference the code here is the same the
protocol is different the syntax is
different but it may not be clear where
that difference is now putting that
aside let's
rearrange the complexity in this
original example instead of having a
function that gets the flag let's create
a structure and we'll call it a range
dictionary and just like a normal
dictionary
it'll look things up but unlike a normal
dictionary it won't look things up
exactly it'll look things up belong to
some range so if the value that it's
looking up is between the range of 0 and
10% they'll give me just an empty string
10% to 50% will give me a single star
50% to infinity I'll give me a double
store and then I'll amend my report so
in my report I just look up the flag
using this lookup and that kind of makes
sense because we know that square
bracket kind of means look something up
so this means in this very last line of
my report look up the flag given the
percent difference and we could see
there's a very close correspondence with
what we originally wrote which used a
function formulation and we're writing
here which is using some kind of look up
some getitem formulation now the actual
mechanism that we might employ to to
make this work might look something like
this we'll have ranged extrema dict
it'll implement part of the object make
part of the dictionary protocol called
missing when you look for a key that
doesn't exist you invoke this this is a
very inefficient implementation because
it's a linear search through the ranges
but you can imagine that you could
recode this as a more efficient maybe
logarithmic search through the ranges
and you could also even add some logic
up here that make sure the ranges are
not overlapping and that there's no gaps
between them but fundamentally beyond
all of those mechanics and I'll hide
this mechanics here once you think about
how this is different than the first
example here if we compare these two and
the first example you have a function
called get flag we have one function
called get flag that tries to figure out
what the flag should be and in the
latter example we have a piece of data
that indicates the flags and a type and
you can see there's the same fundamental
complexity in both of them there in fact
the same operation exists in both of
them if we wanted to make the first one
generic in the same way this is we could
pass in the ranges as a as a piece of
code as a some input data and we'd have
some code that looks like this inside of
that function to figure out are you
within the ranges or not but
fundamentally what's the difference here
well I think what you can see is that
what we've done is we've taken that
fixed amount of complexity and we've
moved it into two places we've moved the
complexity for the lookup mechanism into
the type we move the complexity
for the data that feeds that lookup
mechanism into the data here and so
we've taken that complexity we split it
apart now is that beneficial or not well
this is a lot more sophisticated in
terms of the the use of Python than the
first example but what you could think
is if these ranges were to change later
be a lot safer to change it here then
with the change in the first one if you
wanted to make sure that this was done
correctly not programmatically but just
by you know eyeballing it it's probably
a lot easier to eyeball it here than the
first version and so you can see that
when you can rearrange the complexity in
your program in the right way you might
facilitate certain human actions like
refactoring maintenance or the
confidence of correctness maybe not
automatic or verified correctness but
just human understandability of the code
in different ways now all of that should
remind you of something else from the
Python standard library
you know our chain map and our chain map
is a perfect example of this it's often
the case and the problems that we solve
we have some mechanism that we see
somewhere that looks kind of like layers
or scopes or something like that there's
some lookup and there's some way to add
some layer in front of that lookup to
modify that lookup and that's exactly
what the chain map is it's a data type
that gives you this just chained lookup
and so in the chain map you might have
two resistors and this may be part of
some simulation example you're trying to
do for example you might have the
resistance of the of the network
supplied by the chain map and then when
you want to test something you might
push into this chain map a new value for
the first resistor and when you're done
testing you might just delete it off the
front and what you can see when you run
this example is you know the value of
this resistor goes from ten to fifteen
to ten because the chain map is just a
ordered lookup through these different
maps and the first map that it finds it
in it it returns that value
now you might dislike this because you
can say you know some of this list
manipulation isn't Dell and insert it's
probably not particularly efficient
we're always told to try and avoid those
structures if you want to you can always
be cute in Python people might advise
you not to be cute but you should be who
you are and so you could always swap out
the maps and the chain map for the deck
and now you have very high efficiency
insertion or removal from either side of
the chain map and so now you can write a
very high-performance kind of almost
sort of like a copy-on-write or a Qi
view mechanism on this underlying data
now you probably might not want to use
the same app directly but you can think
if you lift that up into your own custom
type then you can have your custom type
have this very nice automatic you know
undo behavior without having to employ a
very sophisticated mechanism taking the
sophistication of how that undo works
and isolating it in the type itself and
using something from the standard
library to that there are some severe
limitations to this approach to writing
Python one of the questions I asked you
before was what's the difference between
get a target item and pull and get adder
is very very clearly different from the
other to get item and call may be very
similar here's an example of three
things and I'm curious what the
difference is between these two a named
function get item and call and I can do
the same thing it's the syntax is very
very slightly different I switch between
parentheses to square brackets to a
dotted name lookup and then parentheses
very slight differences here what's the
fundamental difference which one do I
choose I'm told that maybe I should
choose one of these two because this
adds unnecessary entities for somebody
who's reading my code to try to
understand so they have to look up what
this means whereas here there may be
some certain assumptions that if you
correctly abide by somebody can read
that code and not have it just take the
assumptions that pop into their head and
continue understanding what the code
does in a very high level before they
have to dig into the documentation
whereas every time you have a dotted
function somebody's going to really feel
like despite what it might what its name
might be I really need to look at the
docs for that and so maybe that's one
guidance but that's a human guidance is
there any technical distinction between
these two and it turns out that there
are there are some significant ones
first what if you need to pass two
arguments in you can't do that with
getitem
game takes literally one argument it's
just the thing to look up right whereas
call can take as many arguments as you
want now you might say well that's not
such a big deal because if I pass in two
arguments I'll pass them in using the
same syntax but it'll be passed in as a
tuple and I'll just de structure that
tuple there that's a little hokey but
where this really breaks is what if it
what if you need to use keyword
arguments there's no possible way to add
keyword arguments in this structure
unless you start mimicking like
JavaScript you know
passing objects to functions there's no
other way to add key word document here
with the nice syntax whereas with your
call there's a way to do key word organs
and so what I said originally was
oftentimes which you might do in Python
is you might start with the simplest
implementation and then increase the
complexity is the complexity of the
problem we're trying to solve increases
when you're choosing how to implement
the parts of the data model that may not
always be the case because sometimes you
can code yourself into a corner for
example imagine that this type here
represented some kind of object database
some storage and you wanted to use the
square bracket lookup to pull some
object out of that database by a path
but then you need to add a modality to
that you know are you running against
the production database for this
database or you're doing a dry run
versus a non dry run or are you doing a
verbose or non verbose you immediately
are no longer able to use the square
bracket syntax because it can no longer
accommodate that keyword argument
modality and so you have to drop back
into using maybe the call protocol and
you'll have to go and rewrite a lot of
code and so sometimes being very
judicious about how you pick which
protocol that you implement may be
important because switching between
these is harder than you might expect in
certain cases or they may or there may
be sufficient technical requirements
that force you into one of these versus
the other now you might say well as a
precaution I'll always only use calling
on ever use square brackets energies
getitem but that may not be that may not
be a wise or judicious move because
there may be cases where this getitem
really is the most natural way to look
at it but you really have to keep at the
forefront of your mind what are the
limitations that I'm buying into there's
another also very serious and severe
limitation here that we haven't talked
about at all but we've hinted at
slightly and I want to talk about one
thing that you may have seen and you may
have wondered about which is a class
method and often times when people talk
about the object model they kind of
think about the object model less well
there's a bunch of underscore methods
there's properties there's static
methods and there's class methods and
that's about it and they say they might
talk about class method as oh it doesn't
take an instance it takes a class and
static method doesn't take any arguments
that may be as deep as they go but
instead I want to guide your you through
a different way to think about some of
these things and one of the other
serious limitations of how you choose to
use a Python object model to implement
this common vocabulary
here I have a simple Network that's
initialized with a set of resistors and
it just stores that information it
doesn't do anything interesting with it
right what if this data came from a file
should I write my in it like this maybe
it takes a file name and if you provide
the file name then you open up that file
and you read the resistors from that and
it's a very common thing I might not
always want to instantiate this object
from data that exists written out in my
program I want to give it a file and
have it figure out how to read and parse
that file and do something with it and
so you might say oh that's not so bad
it's a little bit clumsy because I'm not
sure what I do if I provide both this
argument in this argument but it's not
so bad don't do this one of the
guidances that is not explicate 'add in
the data model documentation for python
is guidance around what an it should
look like and as I told you previously
sometimes it's not worth creating your
own object systems your own kind of
pseudo versions of data classes not data
class in order to avoid writing for
their plate and one of the two or the
two common boilerplates that you might
want to avoid writing or repper and in
it my guidance for you is this init is
always and should always be boilerplate
and it's just boilerplate and just leave
it a boilerplate your NIT should almost
never do anything fancier than setting
attributes checking that you're
constructing a valid object or
constructing derived information you'll
see an example later where we construct
some derived information like we take
the connections of a network coming in
for maybe what the elements are but here
doing something like reading from a file
is a terrible idea
you know why what format is this file in
it's in an XML file ok great I have the
data in CSV format what do I do now am I
gonna pass in an argument called file
name equals this and I'm gonna say if
file name is not none if and I'll use
path Lib file name dot suffix equals
Excel do something here otherwise if
it's something else do something here no
this is gonna be atrocious right and
certainly I do not want to do maybe it
doesn't come from just a file name maybe
it comes from a file name or from a
database do I want to pass extra
arguments and have all these different
ways to construct it and all them at the
of modalities mine it explode and
fundamentally if I can start there from
flower name the replicate how it got
constructed and then you're gonna find
that that round-tripping of the rapper
to the unit it's gonna be very difficult
to make it consistent fundamentally what
you can also think is here and this is
one of the serious limitations that you
have to keep in mind when you're
designing objects in Python the protocol
methods give you a common vocabulary for
how to describe the interrelations
between your objects assuming that for
that each for each element to that
vocabulary there is one privileged
unique meaning for that so in the
previous example we talked about a
network and we talked about using Len to
figure out what the size of the network
was is there only one meaning for the
size of the network well maybe maybe not
maybe in our use case the only one
meaning is the number of elements but
another use case if we were for example
doing some kind of mesh analysis maybe
it's the number of meshes maybe we need
to surface both use cases both the
number of meshes the number of loops
that we're going to compute so that's
the number of rows in our laplace matrix
that will actually have to compute the
the voltage in the car and on the matrix
on or the other network on and maybe
also the elements because we have some
production need to say ok this thing
pass pass some verification step and go
and go through these elements this is
how many elements you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to purchase in order
to produce this know if there are two
meanings which gets to use the
underlying protocol method you can see
this problem here here we're saying
there's many ways to initialize this
object you can initialize from the
actual data or from a file or from a
database or from something else which
ones that one true right way to do it
and if there is no one true White Way
one unique privileged way to implement
that VOC that piece of vocabulary to
call and you should not use a protocol
at all because you're going to end up
confusing somebody because they're gonna
call Len and the result they're gonna
get is not going to comport with their
assumption for what you meant by the
size of the searcher similarly here this
init the arguments that you pass to it
should comport what somebody's
understanding for how to initializes now
an it is special in the case that an
object must have it in it whereas an
object doesn't necessarily have to have
any of the other pieces of the protocol
of the data model and so the guidance
there should be to always have the
unique singular meaning for your for
your objects for the initialization of
your objects to just be initialized them
with the raw underlying data and do a
bunch of boilerplate to set this object
up and don't do anything interesting
don't do any stateful actions don't read
a file don't read from the database
don't do any of that that should be the
answer and what you should instead do is
use class methods think about what class
method does it gives you and it gives
you a class from which you can derive
whatever you want and so what you could
think is all the different ways to
construct this object that are not
constructing it from the raw data itself
can be a class because class methods are
not singular and privileged you can have
as many class methods as you want if you
want to construct this from my file you
can use a class method called from file
if you want to construct it from an
excel file you can use one call from
excel file and these can be duplicated
as you desire and so a class method is
not only this idea that you have some
method that gives you a class and you
can from that construct an instance but
also the idea that this is a mechanism
by which you can add to a class
protocols that are not unique and
privileged but instead might be
duplicated in order to satisfy a variety
of use cases when there's not one
privileged waited for example construct
an object and so that's the general
guidance for where class methods tend to
be used what what you might call factory
functions and the reason why they're
used in that fashion and you should
never use Internet is we no longer have
one privileged way to construct this
object but instead we have multiple
possible ways to distort it now with
that said let's dive a little bit deeper
into the object model and I'll touch
upon a couple of small things that you
might be interested in or might be might
be useful to you to know here we have
our named tuple representation of the
resistor and nothing too fancy there now
when we look at this example here
we can see whoops let's do this one
first we can see that there's a problem
and the data we've passed you pass a
negative resistance which for the
purposes of example shouldn't really
exist these resistors should always be
positive now it may be the case that in
our program that's not an error that
anybody makes and so maybe we don't need
to do anything about it
maybe this is something that could just
as simply be caught by code review but
if it were the case that it was not
something that could be simply caught by
code review or there might be some
additional value to catching it ahead of
time then we may need some mechanism by
which we try to catch that error now one
of the things we could try to do is we
could try to take the name tuple
subclass from it and implement new and
in this new we could check to see if the
resistance was negative and if it was
than to provide an error message and it
say oh it's got to be a positive number
you gave me a negative resistance and
then that gives us some better guidance
but the thing is if it's a named tuple
this thing is immutable so that's a fair
thing to do but if we need this
resistance to be mutable for example if
that potentiometer where we might dial
it back and forth to change the
resistance and it has to just be between
the min and the max value then it very
well need to be the case that we need to
change the resistance later and here in
this case we can't change the reason
because this thing is a it's a subclass
of a tuple it's immutable but if this
were a rich object and we needed to be
able to change this then we need to
figure out some way to do that now if
you're a Java programmers circa Java
like 2015 maybe we might write getters
and setters we might say in order to
prevent this update anomaly or in order
to prevent this anomaly whereby we
change this field to it to invalid value
we're going to force you to go through
this getter in the center to interact
with the underlying data on this on this
class and so here this check that we put
up here might also be duplicated down
here and we do fundamentally get the
ability to check that if you set the
resistance on this thing if you mutate
this thing and set the resistance that
it's
no there's a this would be value that
it's it's indeed positive now the
problem here is that how do we choose
when to write our getters and setters in
fact we may decide that every field
always needs navigator insider because
there could always be some need later
down the line to add validation how do
we know ahead of time that this is the
validation we need and we're told as a
guidance that we should never write code
that hasn't been explicitly asked for us
because it's just going to draw just
gonna add more lines of code that we
didn't have to refactor later as a
business problem changes and so there's
something missing from here now what you
might already know the answer is is that
this is why the property pattern exists
in Python this is why the property
decorator exists the property decorator
gives you the ability to add in hooks
into the lookup or setting of an
attribute after the class has already
been constructed and already been used
and so here in this example I just use
property and then when you try and pull
out the resistance you pull out this
field that has been demarcated as being
private in this instance when you're
trying to set it we put the check here
and then the code works now the guidance
here is that not just that this is
something that we didn't need to have
from day one in fact our first version
of this code might very well just look
like this right
it could just very well look just like
that it doesn't do any checks whatsoever
and maybe there's a bug there but maybe
if that bug is not common enough it's
not does it warrant the effort for those
extra seven lines of code and that's
fine and then when we discover that
there is a requirement we can add in
these two checks here it'll start to
catch invalid code more aggressively but
the rest of the code that we wrote for
this you no longer change the API
doesn't change so we don't have to go
from having a raw attribute to a setter
and a getter however another thing that
I would like you to think about from
this is that what is the difference
between a property and a named function
they both can compute something right
like there's both space here and here to
compute something so what's it ever seen
this and this well clearly you can't fit
arguments into the property right so the
property can operate on the state of the
class but there's no way to fit in
either positional or
keyword arguments so just like the
difference you can get item and call you
can see there's a functional here's a
there's a formal difference between
these two
there's also another difference which is
typically when somebody looks at a
property they don't expect there to be a
computation that's very time-consuming
or that has stateful effect whereas with
a call there's usually a free assumption
for something that might have stateful
effect now as we said before why not
just always use this this syntax what I
always use call it's the least
restricted one of the other principles I
think of Python is you'll often find in
Python that there are do a letís there
are structures that are more flexible
instructions that are less flexible or
more constrained a very simple example
is you have your def formulation for for
writing a function you have a lambda why
bother to use lambda yeah it saves a
couple of lines of code but you can only
have one line you can't have any you
can't have any statements in it can only
be expressions why have list
comprehensions when you can just build
the list with the for loop well the
reason is oftentimes in your reading
through code if somebody makes a choice
of using a more restricted structure
then it helps the reader because they're
guesswork for what actually happens
behind the scenes in order for them to
kind of pierce the veil of that
abstraction is less and so one of the
reasons why you might choose to use a
more restricted a more restricted part
of the data model is not only because
you forecast that you don't need keyword
arguments or some additional
functionality but you're also subtly
broadcasting to the reader that this
thing only does so much and only can do
so much and only will ever be designed
to do so much and so in the case of
property here you're saying this is
something that doesn't need to know any
information other than the current state
of the object whereas call could need
much more information that gets passed
in and you may not always be clear about
what gets passing because it could have
like a star star kwargs argument there
and so there could be fields or that are
that are passed and parameters they're
passing they're not x placated in the
doc string more fundamentally however
this guides us to some information about
something kind of interesting which is
there is part of the Python object model
about how do you look up properties and
so I wanted to do a deep dive into in
the remaining 13 minutes we have I want
to do a deep dive into two parts of the
Python object model to show you how much
flexibility there is what
mentally what I want you to think about
here is that python is not is not
fundamentally dynamic it's more
operationally dynamic in the sense that
somebody has built a model they've added
hook points specific parts you can hook
into those hook points but there are
going to be gaps whereby there's just
not a way to hook into this behavior or
there's a corner case or there's a wart
and so you'll see that even with get add
or get attribute and get you may already
be familiar with get adder we've seen it
before this is what gets hooked when you
do attribute look like ABC right and so
you can see here this get adder just
takes what it's looking up and gives you
the string back upper case very simple
now you might also be familiar that if
this attribute already exists then get
out or doesn't get called so you can see
get add or didn't get called so you may
be familiar that as part of that object
lookup protocol there's actually also a
get attribute that gets triggered before
you actually check to see if that have
to be existed or not and so if you
switch this from get adder to get
attribute suddenly that call is
intercepted and so what you can think
here is that there's some protocol
there's some steps for how you retrieve
an attribute from an object and you go
through those steps and in each step
somebody has de notated these are hook
points one of them is before you even
look it up call get attribute then look
it up normally if it exists there return
it otherwise call get out and even
things like property fit into that
because things like property implemented
using another protocol called the
descriptor protocol what happens is when
you look something up in an object if
you don't see it on the instance and you
don't get it back from get ederoar from
get attribute but you find it on the
class and the thing that you find on the
class has a get method then you call
that kept method so you have yet another
hook point and this is how class method
static method actually no that's not a
static method it works but it's how
class method normal methods and or an
all Python functions actually the class
method normal methods and property are
implemented using this descriptive
protocol and so it's jet another hook
point now the reason to go through these
and the reason to go through this quite
quickly is that knowing exactly the
details of how this protocol works is
less important than knowing that the
protocol exists and knowing that when
you're asking a Python object to give
you an attribute there just tend to be
certain hook points in that and having a
broad awareness those hook points exist
as part of the design of your system the
details of those hook points
our multifaceted like what is this
instance an owner quite mean and what
can we use to employ that there's quite
a lot of detail there but it's not
necessary to know that at a very high
level what's probably most important for
most of you to understand as you set out
to design production systems is that
this exists at all and how it's designed
and structured similarly I want to talk
about the object construction protocol
we know that we can construct an object
by class T and then there's an object
but this is actually dynamic code this
doesn't this isn't C++ this isn't C this
isn't Java there isn't some bag of bits
that represent this class or in C++ and
C no actual runtime representation of
this class but only some compile time
representation to figure out how you can
translate pointer accesses into you know
direct offset you know load operations
this is actually runtime code and we may
be familiar that there's a disk module
in Python and that this module
disassembles code so I have a simple
piece of code like X plus y and it
disassemble it I can see the Python
bytecode a very brief introduction to it
this is the line number this is the
offset for the bytecode this is the
bytecode this is the operand this is the
interpretation of the operand you can
see when we add two values we just call
a binary add and that's how this is how
Python works underneath the covers it's
running through these byte codes it's
running these byte codes it sees the
binary ad and then it dispatches to pi
PI number ad or PI object ad or whatever
one of those methods that go and figure
out what this what this addition
operation actually does in fact in the
case of binary ad it'll first check to
see if that's if they're both unicode
types and then i'll perform a sequence
concatenation as a fast path and
otherwise they'll dispatch to the
numeric addition mechanisms which will
then dispatch to on an american dition
or concatenation operations now one
interesting thing that you might see is
if you try and create a class inside a
function you disassemble that you look
at that you can see this thing called
load build class now if we're running
Python 2 which i really suggest most of
you do because it's going away soon so
you might as well get it just your last
few minutes of Python 2 in it's actually
even easier to see in Python 2 you see
there's a there's a bytecode called
build class and one of the
correspondences that we saw very early
in this talk was a correspondence
between some built-in function sum
underscore method that implements that
built-in function as part of the
vocabulary there's also an other
correspondence
for every one of these bike coats
there's usually or for many of these buy
coats there's a correspondence between
this and some mechanism that implements
that and so it turns out there's a
mechanism that implements how a class is
built in Python there is in fact a
built-in function in the built-ins
called build class and if you write your
own version of it you hook every class
construction and the entire runtime of
your program and so here if we run this
block of code we'll see when we built
this class teeth we hooked into this
code here and we got the function that
would create T in the name of T now
there's not a mechanism that you'll
commonly that you might be aware of in
part because it is not a surgical
mechanism it is a incredibly broad broad
sort and as a consequent is not
particularly useful for anything
production it's not used for any sort of
business logic I'll show you why let's
say we hooked into build class to hook
into when classes were constructed and
then we just very innocently imported
JSON module and data classes module this
hooks into every class construction in
your running program and so it hooks
into a bunch of stuff and there's very
low likelihood you want to hook a notice
all those so this build class mechanism
is there and it exists and what it might
be useful for is if for example you need
to modify certain things like memory
allocation or you want to do some
debugging you want to see what classes
were constructed you wanted to see you
wanted to notate where classes were
constructed when and why you wanted to
do some kind of logging or some kind of
automated testing for example every time
a class is run maybe you run some tests
associated with it and under some
certain debug mode something like that
but other than that it's not
particularly useful more useful might be
the metaclass mechanism now we don't
have enough time to talk about what
amount of class truly is and I gave a
talk about two years ago called how to
be a Python Bob Loblaw expert blah blah
blah
and it got a lot of hits on YouTube
because the title was just provocative
enough that people wanted to click on it
either put you down and say oh that's so
easy that's not Python expertise or they
were genuine student learning about it
but I would suggest you might look up
that talk if you're interested when I'm
at a class truly is so our perspective
here we'll just talk about a metal class
in terms of the mechanism that it
provides it's just a hook into the
object construction process in other
words when you construct the type here
and you give it a meta class there's two
hook points for
that type is constructed once called new
and one coordinate is actually one more
called call I'm going to that here and
there just hook points for when this
object is constructed so if we run this
code we can see as we constructed this T
we got hooks into them and because we
have a hook into the construction of
this T we can do things like modify this
we can add extra fields we do some fancy
things one one fancy thing we might be
able to do is we might be able to supply
the dictionary that's used for
processing the body of that class and so
here this prepare which is actually also
available in Python to gives you the
ability to hook into the dictionary
that's provided for as a namespace for
the constructor in the by this class
which may seem very abstract but you
almost certainly seen something like
this before
that's how enum works in the standard
library this auto think like what is it
- well what's happening is in the enum
enum has a meta class which it's
inherited so this components inherits
that meta class when you inherit that
meta class and you process this code
you're given a dictionary when that
dictionary is filled up actually that's
not actually I'll tell that exactly how
he num works but as a dictionary is
filled up you can do whatever magics you
want one of the things that is necessary
is in Python - you have to provide an
ordered dictionary cuz Python -
dictionaries are longer ordered so you
do have to use prepare that gives you
these in ordered and then you can use
the new or the in it on the meta class
in order to swap out these auto fields
with an actual numerical constant in
Python 3 you just can use auto but in
Python 2 that's not possible because I
didn't add auto to the enum type but it
really only about looks like this in
Python as I said you just provide an
order dict when you're providing the
namespace for executing this class as
you execute this class you just look for
all the items that are auto and if
they're auto items then you replace them
with a numerical value this is how you
can implement this about 15 lines of
code to implement some fairly
sophisticated functionality now again
there's quite a few details here and
this is also Python 2 code so you know
get your last bits of Python 2 in before
it goes away but fundamentally what's
important to understand is that as part
of these as part of building this
universe in Python there are a lot of
these hook points in both get attribute
look up or act or object construction
that give you the ability to customize
how Python does these operations you
might take for granted and so the
combination of all of these
together or what gives you your own
custom object system this is how most
large production systems end up looking
like I don't think we'll have time to go
over the example but in the example I'd
sketched out a couple of places where
you might see that beginning to peak out
most Python systems start very simple
and they don't use any of this
functionality but instead they'll grow
towards having their own custom object
there'll be some set pattern for how all
the objects are designed what the
objects need to have they may use
mechanisms like in its subclass and its
subclasses or is the replacement for or
is the intended replacement for a wide
variety of uses of metaclasses
and in its subclass what you can do is
you can actually do things like you can
add in extra keyword arguments to your
class definition to define things that
should be automatically generated on
that class and so one thing that you
could do is you could make this resistor
you know automatically JSON serializable
automatically decodable from json and
you can provide guidance for how that's
done in the keyword arguments when you
derive this thing here I'm just giving
it some measure information so maybe
it'll be able to print out nicely what
the units are could do some unit
conversion that might be the use case
but that's what it's subclass is for now
the question is if I don't do this
explicitly am I going to end up doing
this implicitly and in my in my
experience most large production systems
in Python end up creating their own
object systems internally and they end
up not using the mechanisms provided to
you by Python and so they end up being
both as complicated as all the examples
that we've looked at so far but much
harder to understand because all of the
mechanisms employed are completely
ad-hoc that were just written on it as
needed and so their final guidance that
I would give you is that it is very
valuable to understand the details of
how all these hopes work it's very
valuable to understand how the Python
object model works because a large
production system not an analytical
system but a production system that has
analytical components will eventually
evolve in this direction and if you
don't understand all of the things that
we've talked about in this session
there's a very high likelihood that the
code will be just as messy and just as
complex as everything we've seen so far
but even harder to understand because I
won't use anything
language so I hope you enjoyed that
think that all the time that we have for
this session that was objectionable
content
I'm James Powell thank you so much
[Applause]